this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by aura
this Legend begins as so many do three
gravediggers working in a cemetery hear
something overhead they look up and see
a creature it's almost 10 feet tall with
massive Wings it's perched on a high
tree branch staring at them with glowing
red eyes then in an instant it's gone
three days later just a few miles away
two young couples burst into the local
police station terrified they report
being chased by a tall man with wings
and glowing red eyes more and more
people would report seeing a creature
that stood on two legs was at least
eight feet tall and had wings some said
it was half man half bird others said it
was half man half bat but the name that
stuck was the Mothman though the Mothman
terrorized hundreds of people for a year
it never physically harmed anyone but 13
months later that would change and 46
men women and children would end up at
the bottom of the Ohio River
[Music]
hey sorry girls I gotta check on the
human
and for centuries the crab cat has
tormented fish snails sea enemies sea
anemones seeing them
hey I was wondering if you were going to
call
where are you yeah I had to get off the
grid so I rented a yacht did you just
belch at me yay yay why you are too yet
it's a type of snow Hut you I know
what a yurt is I'm joking
the address to my safe house leaked
online I get it scary stuff well thank
goodness we
private in foreign line
I might have ended up in a CIA black
site instead of this yay I told you or
is the best all-in-one identity
Protection Service I've ever used easy
to set up easy to use
rubbed my address from the web but you
forgot the dark web I did
to be proactive
emails passwords Social Security numbers
Aura is constantly checking to make sure
your personal information doesn't end up
in the wrong hands and soul you know
hey did you activate aura's VPN on your
phone
that's how aura's one click VPN keeps
your online activity private and scans
your devices for malware and viruses
yep Aura has all the tools you need to
protect yourself and your family from
online threats that you can't see
is that a helicopter yeah hey you gotta
do me a favor and record a message for
my guppies will you we're recording
right now so go for it yay
com slash the white files and sign up
for the two-week free trial Laura will
tell you if any of your information
leaked online that might lead to me and
once you know you're safe email me in my
photo address Big Pop is almost out of
cash that's aura.com the Y files that it
big papa
well I will but do you hear that you're
not worried about that what
the bird what bird look I gotta go we
gotta make 90 clicks before duck and
these guys are already three seats to
the win y'all come over the head boys
what guys where are you going
[Music]
[Laughter]
nestled along the banks of the Ohio
River Point Pleasant West Virginia
words take me home
to please
[Music]
okay okay that's enough take me home
Country Roads
well I'm sorry but if I don't finish it
that song will be stuck in my head all
day less than three miles from one end
to the other Point Pleasant is the type
of town where everybody knows everybody
it's a peaceful place quiet but Point
Pleasant has a Dark and Bloody past in
1774 a few local tribes including the
Mingo and the Shawnee tried to stop
American settlers from encroaching on
their territory on October 10th a fierce
battle was fought between the tribes led
by Chief cornstalk against about a
thousand Virginia militia led by Colonel
Andrew Lewis the battle raged for hours
and eventually became a hand-to-hand
combat the Shawnee Warriors fought
bravely but they were outnumbered two to
one cornstalk had no choice but to
surrender and sign a peace treaty with
the militia three years later in the
fall of 1777 cornstalk and his son
traveled to Fort Randolph which had been
built at the site of the battle
cornstalk wanted to inform the fort's
commander Captain Matthew Arbuckle the
colonists were violating the treaty and
to warn Arbuckle that the British were
trying to recruit tribes to fight
against the American settlers Arbuckle
placed cornstalk and his son under
arrest they were imprisoned along with
two other shawnies that were taken
hostage a few weeks earlier the four
shawnies were well treated but they were
not permitted to leave Arbuckle felt
that as long as he had the hostages the
Shawnee wouldn't attack the fort a few
weeks later a young American was killed
by natives nearby though nobody knows
why or what tribe did it when word
reached the fort a mob of militiamen
shoved Captain Arbuckle aside and
stormed the fort's jail they brutally
executed cornstalk his son and the other
two shawnies but just before cornstalk
died he cursed the settlers and the land
I came to the Fort as your friend and
you murdered me
you have murdered by my side my young
son for this may the curse of the great
spirit rest upon this land
May It Be blighted by Nature may it even
be blighted in its hopes May the
strength of its peoples be paralyzed by
the stain of our blood soon a town
emerged in the area but few settlers
knew their homes were built on top of
mass Graves the skeletons of the battle
of Point Pleasant nor did they realize
their land was cursed over the years
Point Pleasant would indeed be hit with
natural disasters but it would be in
December 1967 when Chief cornstalk
murdered while on a mission of Peace
would take his ultimate Revenge
foreign
the Silver Bridge was a Marvel of
engineering and a source of Pride for
the local community it connected Point
Pleasant West Virginia to Gallup police
Ohio and thousands of vehicles crossed
every day it was Rush Hour on December
15 1967 and the bridge was packed it was
Friday night and commuters were rushing
home to get a jump on the weekend
holiday Shoppers had cars filled with
Christmas gifts as the sun set and
Twilight descended over the bridge
traffic slowed to a halt suddenly
allowed crack Was Heard and then an
unnatural screeching sound before anyone
realized what happened
people in their cars watched in horror
as the bridge buckled and began to shake
violently the sound of Steel twisting
and tearing was deafening the scene was
something out of a nightmare people
screamed and ran in all directions
desperately trying to escape the chaos
but for people on the bridge it was too
late in just a few moments the entire
Bridge collapsed into the icy waters of
the Ohio River 36 cars and trucks fell
into the river dragging their passengers
down with them the water was freezing
and the current was strong rescue
attempts were almost impossible we heard
this terrible boom and my boys looked
around and saw the bridge starting to
fall
in the aftermath 44 bodies of men women
and children were pulled from the river
and another two people were never found
in the days leading up to the Silver
Bridge collapse people in the area
reported a feeling of unease that they
couldn't quite explain two photos of the
bridge were taken about a week before
the disaster whoa what the hell is that
people passing through the area saw a
bat-like creature hovering near the
bridge a creature that locals called the
Mothman
the TNT area of Point Pleasant got its
name because during World War II it was
the location of the West Virginia
Ordinance Works a large weapons Factory
after the war the factory was abandoned
and not long after that the area became
a Dumping Ground for toxic waste and
dangerous chemicals and not long after
that the area became a center of strange
activity UFOs were often seen in the
area some people's dogs would become
agitated by something run out to the
woods to investigate and then disappear
on November 2nd 1966 Woodrow derenberger
is driving through the area on his way
home he sees some kind of craft landed
in the middle of the road derenberger
stops his car and a door on the craft
opens out walks and ordinary man
derenberger describes him as having
average height and build and dark hair
but he did wear an unusual and a natural
looking broad grin The Strange man tells
derenberger telepathically that his name
is injured cold from a planet called
lanulus over the next few years cold
would visit would roderenberger several
more times that very same night two men
had to stop their vehicle when a craft
landed in the road directly in front of
them batcraft opened and out walked an
ordinary man with a wide grin the men
said the stranger asked them odd
questions then got back in the craft and
took off into the sky again on that same
night a woman in the next town over sees
a bright flash in the sky then a
cylinder-shaped craft lands in a parking
lot it opens and two men come out they
asked her strange questions in an odd
dialect then they got back in their ship
and flew away all these people seem to
be describing injured Cole and the story
of injured cold is a wild one so let me
know if you want me to cover it the area
around Point Pleasant was suddenly
flooded with Paranormal Activity not
just UFOs but other lights in the sky
poltergeists and ghosts were being seen
electrical disturbances were burning out
people's televisions telephones were
ringing at all hours day and night but
there was nothing on the line but static
and it all started happening when on
November 1st 1966 the night before the
grinning man appeared a national
Guardsman reported seeing a half-man
half-bird watching him from high in a
tree after a minute it disappeared two
weeks later the Birdman was seen again
four men were working in a cemetery
digging a grave as the sun set they saw
a flying man hovering right over the
cemetery three days later on November
15th Roger and Linda scarberry decided
to go for a drive they picked up their
friends Steve and Mary Millette and
cruised through the TNT area driving
past an old Power Plant they saw a tall
man standing in the road
but as they got closer they realized it
wasn't a man at least not a normal man
it was a humanoid creature at least
seven feet tall pale with wings folded
on its back
one of the witnesses Linda scarberry
said its eyes glowed red and were
hypnotic and disturbing as they got
closer it ran toward the power plant and
disappeared in a panic Roger floored it
and tore away down the Dark Country
Roads
Take me home I'm trying to build tension
and you're making it really hard pal I
know I'm sorry but it's stuck in my head
now you have to admit that song is a bit
of a near worm it is but we have work to
do can we try to get back to the drama
you're right you're right that's my
fault keep going all right uh where am I
you made me lose my place yeah they were
flying down the dog country road right
okay uh Roger floored it and tore away
down the Dark Country Road
what now you were humming was I
well demeanor well they lost the
creature and had a second to gather
their thoughts Roger Linda and their
friends decided to go to the Sheriff's
Department to warn the town they didn't
expect anyone to believe them but they
felt they had to try then a few miles
down the road they couldn't believe
their eyes perched on a billboard was
the creature it was following them when
they drove past it the creature spread
its wings and launched straight up into
the air
and no matter how fast they drove or
what turns they made the creature stayed
with them they hit a straightaway and
gunned the engine 70 miles an hour the
creature could keep up 80 miles an hour
and it was still with them
every so often it would swoop down
toward their car and let out a
terrifying Screech
they had to go faster when they hit 90
they thought they lost it but a few
minutes later they heard the Screech it
was flying about 50 feet behind them but
gaining it had to go faster
now pushing a hundred miles an hour on a
dark Road they were worried about
crashing or flipping the car but as they
approached the lights of the town the
creature slowed its Chase and
disappeared when they arrived at the
sheriff's department they were surprised
to hear that people were seeing the
creature all over the area and this was
only the beginning
the day after the flying creature chased
the scarboroughs and the malets away
from the power plant Marcella Bennett
was visiting her brother in the same
area around 9pm Marcella left her
brother's house with her four-year-old
daughter when she reached for the handle
of the car door she saw what looked like
legs then she heard her brother yelling
for her to get back in the house as her
eyes slowly moved up she saw a humanoid
creature at least seven feet tall with
wings as soon as Marcella saw its red
eyes she was frozen her brother kept
yelling but she couldn't move after a
couple of seconds she snapped out of it
stumbled dropped her daughter and fell
her brother ran out grabbed them both
and bolted for the door the creature
unfurled its wings and pursued but they
were able to make it inside they locked
the door the creature banged on the door
a few times and even tried the doorknob
a few seconds later it was gone word
quickly got around and the local papers
picked up the story they call this tall
human-like creature with wings and red
eyes the Mothman on November 20th 15
people saw the Mothman on 4 four
different occasions on November 21st
another sighting on the 25th another on
the 26th seven people saw the Mothman on
five different occasions on November
28th fayla port and her brother drove
out to the TNT area they stopped at the
old Power Plant to see if they could
find the Mothman hey did they find it
Well it found them first
now Faye was face to face with the
Mothman a few feet from the car window
care for what you wish for her yep she
said it had glowing red eyes nothing
like she'd ever seen she didn't see any
wings but it was running fast enough to
keep up with the car they screamed at
her brother to drive faster but no
matter how fast they went they couldn't
lose it they whipped around a turn
slammed on the brakes and the Mothman
jumped on the hood of their car and
stared at them they and her brother
stayed completely still terrified to
move Faye and her brother looked for the
Mothman but they didn't see it but
finally they saw it perched on the roof
of an abandoned building nearby so
Faye's brother slowly gets out of the
car what is he nuts and he's picking up
chunks of coke he was picking at him
just throwing it and going shoo shoo
yeah he's nuts then the Mothman opened
its wings and flew off into the darkness
the following week three more separate
sightings the week after that the
Mothman is seen four times by 18
different people I saw
you know this big
bird looking thing
go over top of my car
I could see it wasn't a man that it
looked more like a bird instead of arms
they were like wings
I had a huge wingspan I was at least 10
feet I was paralyzed I just and I just
thought well yeah I'm gonna die people
describe the Mothman the same way over
seven feet tall with glowing red eyes a
grayish Brown body and huge Wings these
descriptions matched even before the
news reported on the story speculation
went wild nobody had ever seen a
creature like this anywhere on Earth
that's when a new theory was proposed
that the Mothman was from somewhere else
foreign
was a prominent ufologist and paranormal
researcher he's most well known for the
movie The Mothman Prophecies which is
based on his novel of the same name when
the Mothman sightings read their height
Keel traveled to Point Pleasant to
investigate he spent months interviewing
Witnesses and local reporters he studied
police reports and legends and myths
from the area John Keel was trying to
unravel The Mystery of the Mothman but
he soon became a Target he started
having headaches and episodes of extreme
paranoia cryptic messages would appear
on his answering machine sometimes
without the phone ever ringing he was
constantly followed by mysterious men in
dark suits exactly in fact John Keel is
the one who coined that term he noticed
his mail is being opened and resealed
his phone was tapped where some people
theorized that the Mothman wasn't
extraterrestrial John Keel thought the
creature could be what he called an
ultra-terrestrial this is an entity
that's from Earth but lives in a
different dimension a dimension that we
can't perceive and that exists outside
of time these entities can materialize
and dematerialize any place in any time
they want they do this by adjusting
their energy to match different
wavelengths on the electromagnetic
spectrum Kiel said these beings Go by
different names in different cultures
some call them Spirits or fairies or
angels in the Middle East they're called
Jinn you may have even seen one yourself
because they're also called the dark
Watchers the hatman Shadow People
what grad kit it's half crib and a half
cat I know what it is but what does it
happen they simply Whispering its name
it can be summoned from its evil
Dimension with fish are used for food
fish are food in this Dimension you take
heed Guppies and fear the crib kit okay
the area around Point Pleasant is a hot
spot for paranormal phenomena like the
Mothman and UFOs John Keel said there
are a few locations like this on the
planet he called them window areas in
these window areas human consciousness
itself can summon these beings or even
conjure a UFO some UFOs are directly
related to the human consciousness just
as ghostly apparitions are often the
product of the precipient's Mind there
are deeply rooted psychic and
psychological factors in the UFO
phenomena and the sudden appearance of a
light in the sky triggers and releases
the human energy that stimulated
seemingly Supernatural events this
cosmological system of control has been
in effect since the dawn of humanity oh
so humans are the ones creating all the
weird stuff yep and John Keel didn't
just invent the theory out of the blue
the way to conjure a gin is to think
about one same with shadow people there
are many theories and philosophies that
say everything in the universe including
human consciousness is energy
a few weeks ago we did an episode on the
Gateway process which is a technique to
tap into this energy and once you're
tapped in you can conjure anything you
want simply by thinking about it now
this may sound like Hocus Pocus but the
CIA and the American Military spent
years researching this well that
explains the Men in Black it could men
in dark suits were visiting local
residents asking them to describe the
things they saw John Keel also thought
The Mothman and beings like it were
Omens of impending doom this is why he
called this book The Mothman Prophecies
these entities would often show up
before a terrible event but he didn't
know if they wanted to warn people or
simply observers or were actually the
ones causing the event the Silver Bridge
collapsed was one of the worst disasters
the town ever endured every person in
Point Pleasant was affected everyone had
a friend on the bridge a loved one A
co-worker a child it wasn't until after
the bridge collapsed the people started
connecting the event to the Mothman in
the days and weeks leading up to the
disaster Mothman sightings were becoming
more and more frequent and as soon as
the bridge came down and dragged 46
people to icy Graves sightings of the
Mothman stopped did the Mothman
accomplish what it set out to do nobody
really knows why the creature arrived or
why it left the fact that it was finally
gone was good news for the people of
Point Pleasant but it was bad news for
the people of Binghamton New York
because eight years later the Mothman
was back
[Music]
after the collapse of the Silver Bridge
in 1967 the people in Point Pleasant
stopped seeing the moth band UFO
encounters reports of ghosts the Men in
Black all these suddenly stopped
whatever the Mothman was doing in West
Virginia it must have served its purpose
but that wouldn't be the last we hear of
the moth ban not even close in 1975 in
Binghamton New York a group of children
reported seeing a large creature they
described as a man with bat wings and
glowing red eyes
three years later a group of minors in
Freiburg Germany came face to face with
a creature with glowing red eyes at
first they thought it was a man in a
trench coat but then it unfurled large
black wings the men stared and stunned
silence until the creature let out a
blood curdling Screech that sent the
miners running about an hour later the
men felt the Earth shake that a plume of
dust shot from the mine as it collapsed
if the men had gone to their stations as
usual most of them would have been
killed the creature they called the
Fryeburg Shrieker actually saved their
lives throughout 1985 workers at the
nuclear power plant in Chernobyl claimed
to see a huge black bird-like creature
flying around the plant it had the body
of a man and red eyes they called it the
Blackbird of Chernobyl people in the
area started receiving strange phone
calls with nothing on the line but
static even more people had nightmares
and these incidents got worse and worse
until the Chernobyl explosion in April
1986. there was a Mothman scene and
photographed near the Twin Towers in
2001 before the 9 11 attack in August
2007 after a month of Mothman sightings
the I-35 bridge collapsed during rush
hour a large red-eyed creature
terrorized the people of La Junta Mexico
in 2009 shortly after there was a swine
flu outbreak in 2011 people started
seeing a giant flying humanoid creature
all over the Chicago area like all over
for example what the heck is this
foreign
[Music]
there have been hundreds of Mothman
sightings around the airport including
photos and some crazy video what the
hell is that it looks like Khaleesi is
coming to burn King's Landing whatever
it is the way it's flying it's big
Skeptics say that's a bird but it
doesn't look like a bird to me the
website phantomsandmonsters.com has been
tracking all the sightings in the area
they even have an interactive map and
I'll link it below if you want to check
it out they've been compiling emails
phone calls and interviews from
eyewitnesses working at the airport I
had just left work at the USPS shorting
facility at O'Hare International Airport
I was walking out to my car when I saw
something standing at the far end of the
parking lot where I usually park at
first I thought it was a very tall
person with a long coat as I got closer
to my car I unlocked my car which caused
my headlights to come on my headlights
hit the person standing about 20 to 25
feet from my car causing it to turn and
looked right at me I saw that this was
not some person but some red-eyed being
and what appeared to be a coat were
actually Wings which had spread out as
it turned to look at me this thing then
started making some kind of chirping
sound almost a half chirp and half click
like someone was clicking their tongue
but much faster it Finn made some type
of screeching sound and took off running
toward me it got to within 10 feet of me
and took off into the air and flew above
me I got home and told my husband who
also works at the same facility and he
was the one who told me about the
sightings of this thing I was scared
shitless and I hope I never see this
thing again there are all kinds of
stories like this by reliable Witnesses
including airport security officers who
have a lot to lose by sounding crazy my
name is and I'm a security guard at
O'Hare I'm reluctantly writing to you to
report something that I saw a week ago
on the night of Tuesday December 3rd
2019 I was heading toward one of the
Airport cargo hubs I was approaching the
creek and headed toward Montrose Avenue
but I saw this large person standing
down in the creek bed I stopped thinking
it was maybe a trucker who decided to
wander down there to relieve himself I
put on my lights and stopped my vehicle
and Was preparing to get out when this
man turned toward me and I saw two very
bright red eyes this thing appeared to
be looking straight at me and it had
turned away and walked away as it did it
unfurled a set of wings it took off into
the air and was gone into the darkness I
was left there wondering what in the
hell it just happened and what I had
just seen I'm going to be blunt here I
don't believe in hobgoblins and Little
Green Men and I'm sure that there must
be a rational explanation for this I
have worked too hard to get where I am
and to have all that trash by saying
that I saw a red-eyed flying man yet
that is what I saw I'm torn between
reporting this and keeping my mouth shut
to protect my retirement if I do report
this I want everything to be done to
protect my identity Pilots even saw it
my name is Bruce and I'm a pilot for and
I've been with since 2008. the incident
I'm about to tell you happened on
Thursday August 8th 2019 at O'Hare
International Airport at approximately
1800. I'd flown into O'Hare the previous
day and it stayed at a hotel for the
night I was due to fly out at 2000 to
the UK I was taking the airport shuttle
toward the terminal as I looked out the
window I saw a large human with Enormous
Wings and glowing red eyes perched upon
a rail and looking straight at me I was
startled and I'll admit it very
frightened it did not move or attempt to
hide itself as we approached knowing
that it could be clearly seen team it
just stay put and washed as we passed
when we passed I tempted to look back
and see if we still perched there I saw
nothing and can only assume that it must
have flown off when we passed it's even
been seen by air traffic control I've
worked at O'Hare for the last seven
years as a member of the air traffic
control team I was working the late
evening at traycon and have just walked
away from one of our mandatory breaks I
was walking toward one of the terminal
buildings when I noticed some movement
out of the corner of my eye I turned in
the direction of the movement and
noticed a large black shape coming to a
rest on the ground near a light pole
this thing was at least six to seven
feet tall and jet black and it looked
like a very big bat but was also very
human-like in appearance it sported a
large set of black wings that also
looked like the wings of a bat they were
open to their full length and must have
did at least 12 feet it kept its head
down looking at the ground until an
approaching vehicle startled it that is
where I saw that a Ted was short and
squat but had a pair of piercing red
eyes it looked in the direction of the
approaching vehicle and then began to
flap its wings and took to the air it
disappeared above the building in a span
of one to two seconds and was gone out
of sight I personally know of three
other controllers who have had sightings
of this thing and just as many pilots
who have either reported sightings in
and around the airport
and the Chicago Mothman sightings are
still coming in as recently as a few
weeks ago multiple Witnesses reported a
red-eyed humanoid with wings it was
pursed on top of a building staring at
them when it spread its wings its
wingspan was according to the witnesses
wider than a car it made a chirping
sound then flew over them and up and out
of sight now the Chicago Mothman has
been seen for at least 12 years so
luckily it doesn't seem to be predicting
Doom for the city oh I take it you
haven't been to Chicago recently
[Music]
oh
the Mothman is one of the most seen most
widely reported cryptids in the world
it's been seen in every country and
often by reliable Witnesses so what is
the moth ban is it really a flying
humanoid with glowing red eyes and giant
Wings well there are a few theories one
is it's an alien I like it in the Point
Pleasant area Mothman sightings
coincided with UFO reports so naturally
people connected them that would also
explain why the Men in Black showed up
some locals thought the Mothman was an
angel I like it trying to warn people
about the bridge collapse an interesting
theory is that the Mothman is a new
species one that mutated from the toxic
waste and chemicals dumped in the TNT
area I love it to Skeptics this may
sound unlikely but scientists recently
discovered that wild dogs in the
Chernobyl area are mutating and evolving
faster than other dogs you know what
they say extra dogs are an x-man's best
friend well I don't know if any dogs
have been discovered with superpowers
but exposure to radiation has made their
DNA different and distinct from regular
dogs now in an area that's supposed to
be highly toxic these X dogs are
flourishing but there are a few
non-supernatural explanations in The
Point Pleasant area specifically during
the first Mothman sightings sandhill
cranes were migrating sandhill cranes
are big birds they can grow to almost
five feet tall and their wingspans can
easily reach six feet or more they also
have red markings on their heads which
could explain why people see what they
think are red eyes but even the biggest
crane is not big enough to fit the
description of the witnesses unless it's
a mutant expert right unless it's that
another common explanation is that what
people thought was the Mothman was an
unusually large barn owl barn owls have
large eyes and in the dark their eyes
shine red this is from a layer of eye
tissue that reflects light around the
retina multiple times allowing them to
see extremely well in the dark it's
called tapedum lucidum in fact almost
all nocturnal creatures emit an eye
shine headlights on dark roads in the
woods would reveal all kinds of animals
with eye Shine from something as large
as a bear all the way down to a spider
now barn owls don't get anywhere close
to large enough to fit the description
but there have been studies that show
when humans are in motion it's difficult
for us to determine the size of an
object the faster we're moving the
harder it is zooming along at 70 miles
an hour past a five foot tall bird with
a 10-foot wingspan that bird might look
huge and in forensic psychology there's
something called the weapon Focus effect
it says that when people are under
stress specifically fear their memories
are unreliable for example when someone
is a victim of armed robbery they tend
to focus on the weapon and not other
details of the scene that would explain
all the sightings in Chicago
martialic found that when people view a
disturbing image they were highly
confident in their memory of that image
even if their memory was wrong
we know that human memory is already
unreliable if we recall an event a
certain way our brains will eventually
create the memories to fit even if our
recollection is completely wrong so when
four people start telling each other
they saw a seven foot tall Mothman it
won't take long for the memories to be
created when these false memories are
shared by multiple people it's called a
transactive memory and then you have
mass hallucination and mass hysteria
where people think they're seeing a
threat but they only see it because they
were already afraid of it so we have all
these Mothman sightings happening around
Point Pleasant and then John Keel comes
along and writes a book about it the
book becomes a runaway hit the
information in the book then adds to the
group's memory the problem with that is
John keel's book was a fiction novel The
Connection of the Mothman to the Silver
Bridge Keel made that up because it
makes the story more interesting same
with the weird phone calls and
electronic disturbances Keel invented
those too if you go back and read
eyewitness testimony you'll see that
nobody reported weird phone calls until
after the book came out John Keel also
made up the part about the Men in Black
the witnesses who say they saw Men In
Black they didn't mention it before the
book's release John keel's notes and
letters have been thoroughly analyzed
the information in the Mothman
Prophecies is vastly different than the
notes he took during his investigation
now the legend says that over a hundred
people saw the Mothman in Point Pleasant
but the actual number of incidents is
just six or seven now that's still
something but clearly lots of people
wanted to jump on the attention
bandwagon if you read the later witness
reports some of them are ripped right
out of scary children's stories and
other urban legends now why did the
Mothman sighting stop right after the
collapse of the Silver Bridge because
the people in Point Pleasant now had a
real tragedy to deal with it snapped
them out of their group memory and gave
them something very real to focus on but
even with all these attempts to explain
the Mothman Skeptics still come up short
the sightings in Chicago are real maybe
not all of them but some of them are and
back in Point Pleasant before the
newspaper reported anything about the
Mothman I eyewitnesses who didn't know
each other described the creature the
same way if you follow this channel you
know I don't like doing stories about
Cryptids this is because there's rarely
compelling evidence and there are never
any good pictures but in the process of
researching The Mothman I might have
come around if just a little I don't
know if the Mothman exists but people
are seeing something so if you're ever
driving at night through the Rolling
Hills of West Virginia or stumbling to
the car rental after a red eye to O'Hare
pay close attention listen for an odd
clicking or chirping sound coming from
the Shadows look for two glowing red
eyes watching you from the dark but
don't be afraid the Mothman has never
hurt anyone but if I were you I'd stay
away from Bridges for a while just in
case
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ there's
hacklefish this has been the y-files and
if you had fun or learned anything do us
a favor like comment subscribe share I
know I'm a broken record but that stuff
really really helps like most topics we
cover on the channel today's was
recommended by you lots of you and if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to yfiles.com tips a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible you guys are
incredible I can't thank you enough if
you'd like to be part of an incredible
Community join the y-files Discord it's
completely free but if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon or grab something from
the Wi-Fi store oh we should put some
more men t-shirts up there they're
already up there pal oh you magnificent
best that's gonna do it until next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
thank you
[Music]